let's check in with our caller from the
eight one five area code who's calling
today from eight one five hi this is
Jonathan from Rockford Illinois hey
Jonathan hi I just had a quick question
about um so considering the current
state of our like political climate
particularly like what the DNC you know
trying to rally against Bernie and
obviously about ideological differences
with from Republicans with Democrats
would you see like hypothetically if
Bernie was to become president do you
think his term would even be successful
considering that there's so many people
going against him both on the left and
right and so like his policies are like
Medicare for all you know universal
education all that what do you me
successful in trying to convince other
people to sign on to that even if you
were to be President
well I've taught when I've talked about
this before in the context of health
care I was absolutely crushed by a huge
portion of the Bernie supporters in my
audience and remember I'm voting for
Bernie in the primary no you're
absolutely right which is that if it's
Bernie versus Trump Bernie's the right
choice and we vote for Bernie and
hopefully Bernie wins and he gets as
much done as possible and he will get
some things done but when you have a
significant part of the Democratic
Senate not in favor of Medicare for all
when you have the filibuster when you
have all of these other things of course
Bernie's not going to get everything
done that he promises and that's no
different than any candidate every every
candidate has Trump is gonna do a wall
he was going to do new health care he
was going to eliminate the deficit and
eventually pay off the debt like he's
not doing any of that stuff now those
things were completely unrealistic to
begin with but needless to say it
wouldn't be a new thing that someone is
brought into office and their ambition
is bigger than what they can accomplish
that is a perfectly realistic and
sensible thing to talk about the
question though is what can we get done
and making sure that right that we do it
but you're completely right anybody who
argues that you're being a defeatist is
being completely unrealistic yeah I
totally agree cuz you know I don't think
that you know you have to be realistic
especially right now you know you got to
take your victories where you can and
so I totally agree and I also wanted to
ask for so like obviously with the rise
of Bloomberg and his like you know he
has obviously he's been the mayor of New
York and he has some political
experience but for someone like Trump or
you know Tom Steyer do you think it's
time and I know this probably would
never happen but that we updates like
qualifications for the presidency that
involved like maybe having some type of
political experience holding some type
of office or you know just maybe
updating what we have already you know I
don't so first of all it would be very
difficult to add new requirements but I
actually I don't think that political
experience should be required I would
like it if the electorate was more
informed about if you lack political
experience what other sort of experience
would be a good replacement I don't
think being a reality show host and
using your dad's money to still run a
business that goes bankrupt a bunch of
times like that doesn't qualify for me
but I wouldn't want to add more
requirements the only things I would
consider adding are maybe we should have
a president presidential candidates
major Party presidential candidates
undergo a full cognitive assessment and
I think that that particularly this
presidency has made relevant but no I
wouldn't add more requirements about I
don't believe it would be constitutional
and it would be very very difficult to
achieve and I don't think it's the right
thing either okay all right fair enough
all right well those are all my
questions so thank you David all right
thanks appreciate the phone call very
very much
that is going to do it for today I do
apologize I wasn't able to get to
everyone but it is great that there are
more people calling in
than the number that I can get to
because otherwise it would be very very
sad we will take calls again we will
take a quick break and then I will be
back with much more right after this